[Music]  it's Nicole that is dunnies that  gorgeous  Nikki Bella was glowing as she shopped  for her wedding gown but she had a hard  time saying yes to more than just the  dress you and wedding dresses though  just yeah coloring and I'll make  everything right wedding dress  might as well walk down the aisle I  don't know I thought you're supposed to  be excited for this like when you watch  the movies or all I hear from my friends  is like oh my gosh greatest day break  out the champagne and like for me I'm  just like okay let's make this quick I  don't know there's just something that's  not feeling raped that moment caught by  total Bellas cameras before Nikki and  John Cena called off their engagement  also featured this confession from the  34 year-old while the fairytale didn't  pan out as planned Nikki still has  nothing but positive things to say about  her ex  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]